[Música]
es aquí donde la elección de eeuu puede
dar un giro de cualquier manera los
estados pendular es donde demócratas y
republicanos disfrutan de niveles
similares de apoyo entre los votantes
estos campos de batalla pueden
constituir una parte significativa de
los 270 votos en el colegio electoral
necesarios para ser elegido presidente
de eeuu estos estados valen tanto el
tiempo como el dinero ya que ambos
partidos intentan cortejar a los
votantes antes del último día y la
historia ha demostrado que estos
esfuerzos dan resultados richard nixon
fue derrotado por john f.kennedy en 1960
después de perder illinois y texas en
2000 fueron los votantes de florida y
new hampshire quienes le entregaron a
george w.bush las llaves de la casa
blanca bush luego obtuvo un segundo
mandato cuatro años después superando a
john kerry gracias a una mayoría en el
estado de ohio
el éxito de donald trump en 11 estados
pendulares fue clave para vencer a
hillary clinton en 2016
y este año algunos de los estados donde
los votantes esperan lo inesperado son
arizona wisconsin michigan florida
pensilvania y carolina del norte